the deaths of beloved tv characters can
shock viewers like nothing else
they might feel sudden but they've often
been planned years in advance
so we're here to examine those
characters who were doomed from episode
one
premiering on stars in 2014 the crime
drama power
follows nightclub owner drug kingpin
james ghost st
patrick he's a family man and
entrepreneur
who poses as a pillar of the community
on the strength of his rags-to-riches
facade
secretly his best friend is his partner
in literal crime
and the first season sees him embark
upon an extramarital affair with his
middle school sweetheart
ghost is brought to life by actor omari
hardwick who entices viewers with his
sharp suits
menacing focus and chiseled good looks
ghost's secret life of crime is destined
to catch up to him in the end though
in the final season he's shot dead by
his son tariq
as it turns out power creator courtney a
kemp
always planned to have ghosts die as she
wrote in the los angeles times
the series is about consequences for
their actions the characters always
caused their own deaths
one way or another sons of anarchy
premiered on fx in 2008 hooking fans
with its
killer characters and gruesome scenes of
gun violence and gang battles
and lead character jax teller quickly
became beloved by fans
as the prodigal son who's set to take
charge of the california motorcycle crew
his father once led
he must manage his overbearing mother
life as a new father
and his own torn emotions over the one
who got away
over the course of seven seasons he
works to transform the trajectory of his
crew
so that violence and criminal activity
are no longer at the forefront of their
lives
during this time he and his loved ones
endure plenty of terrifying struggles
in the end he sacrifices himself for the
well-being of the crew
this sounds like a lot for writers to
put a character through but in a 2014
interview with e
executive producer paris barclay made it
clear that this was always the plan for
jax
as he put it i knew that he wasn't going
to end up at a carnival buying snow
cones for his sons
and that was the last shot i always knew
this was going to end badly
what happens at the end of the day
the bad guys lose in 2018
the sons of anarchy legacy continued
with the premiere of the spin-off mayans
mc
which centers on a tight-knit motorcycle
crew in mexico
it remains to be seen if the lead actor
on that show will also experience a
shocking demise
michael k williams is a phenomenal actor
who often portrays conflicted
individuals
who tend to overshadow the protagonists
from chalky white on boardwalk empire
to montrose freeman on lovecraft country
he seamlessly transforms into dark and
enigmatic characters that audiences
grow to love on the hbo series the wire
he played omar little a stick of guy who
robs drug dealers and keeps them on
their toes
the baltimore set crime drama has been
hailed as a classic
and frequently cited as one of the
greatest shows in television history
omar stands out as an especially great
part of the series
thanks to the strategic way he runs the
streets his well-rounded moral compass
and his unique status as a gay man tv
viewers in the early 2000s had truly
never before seen a queer character like
omar on a gritty crime show
in the final season omar is killed in a
convenience store by a young drug dealer
in 2008 williams shared his feelings
about his character's death with mtv
news
as he revealed that he'd always known it
was going to happen
as he put it it took me for a loop i was
also saddened
not that he was dying because when i got
the job they told me season one
omar was only going to be around for
seven episodes after that
expect a bullet it's still hurt five
years
you walk with this dude you know the
dude real well
he added the people of baltimore i got
to know the streets
how they walk how they eat how they
dress
i soaked all of that up i feel like i
lost one of my best friends
a man got to have a cold in house of
cards first season
newspaper journalist zoe barnes is the
key to frank underwood's demise
underwood holds many secrets some have
the power to destroy his growing
political career
while others could destroy his
calculated marriage
zoe is also seduced by the criminal
congressman
as she learns more about him she shares
her intel with her boss
but she also grows fearful as frank
begins to stalk
and antagonize her he ultimately follows
her into a subway station
and pushes her onto the tracks her death
is swift
cold and shocking house of cards
executive producer david fincher
usually employs a dark visual style to
his films
so perhaps it's no surprise that his
foray into tv followed suit
nevertheless fans were blown away by the
sinister scene
when series creator beau willimon spoke
with the hollywood reporter in 2014
he revealed that zoe's death had been
planned from the beginning
as he explained we told kate mara from
the get-go
i always knew that zoe was going to meet
her maker in the first episode of season
2.
he later added she's so wonderful that
as we got closer to doing it
we reconsidered for a second then we
stuck to our guts
amazon's the boys explores an alternate
universe in which people with
extraordinary gifts are labeled soups
and attract the attention of
conglomerates
the powerful corporation vod
international has created a team of
celebrity soups called the seven
who fight crime and work to save
humanity but this work
is actually a facade when the cameras
and capes are off
many members of the seven lead
challenging lives and are even dangerous
to humanity
take for example lamplighter a former
member of the seven played by sean
ashmore who has the ability to set
things ablaze
he's mentioned quite a bit in season 1
though he doesn't actually appear until
season 2.
the truth about his complex allegiances
is eventually revealed
and then he sets himself on fire after
the episode aired
ashmore told tv line it was such a bold
choice
the way that i look at death scenes is
if you're gonna go out on a show or on a
film
it better be good and it better be
impactful
when loss premiered on abc in 2004 it
seemed fairly straightforward
as a group of plane crash survivors came
together to figure out life on a
deserted island
but over the course of its six season
run it became clear
over and over again that it was anything
but simple
there are supernatural elements to the
island and every survivor has a
complicated past that led them there
anna lucia cortes for one was on the
plane's tail section
and emerged as a leader in season two
she puts her lapd skills to use on the
island but she also gains a lot of
enemies in doing so
she's eventually killed by fellow
survivor michael
in a 2006 interview with tv guide lost
show runners damon lindelof
and carlton hughes discuss details about
analysis
arc as they developed the character and
put the casting word out
they heard from michelle rodriguez's
agent that she was interested in the
role
but only for one season as lindelof
recalled
she wanted to do one kick-ass arc as she
described it
and we basically started to wrap our
brains around her energy and say
yeah we'll bring you on the show and
then we'll kill you off at the end of
the year
i can't do this anymore when tara
knowles pops up on sons of anarchy in
charming california
jax teller is stunned they loved each
other in high school
but tara left to focus on her studies
she comes back as a doctor
finding jackson pretty bad shape with a
drug-addicted girlfriend
and a new baby despite their hiccups and
hurdles
the sweethearts manage to stick it out
as they get married and have a son of
their own
but tara is always at odds with jax's
overbearing mother
gemma for her part gemma is wary of
tara's true intentions
while also desiring to maintain her
position as the most important woman in
her son's life
she ends up killing tara while acting on
false information
jax is devastated and never recovers
from the pain
katie seagal who played gemma and is
married to show creator kurt sutter had
hoped that he would change his mind
about tara's death
but sutter stood firm having decided
that jax needed the major emotional
shift that this provided as the series
approached its ending
over the course of lost six seasons
viewers discover that jack shepherd is
more than the self-appointed leader of
the survivors
he's also been connected to them for
years through flashbacks these links are
revealed
as are the shameful mistakes of his past
that led him to oceanic flight 815
he grapples with his estranged
relationship with his father
his love for kate and his animosity for
sawyer who challenges jack's leadership
early versions of lost actually killed
jack and the pilot
and made kate the group's leader as
critic alan seppewa
wrote in his book the revolution was
televised in the vein of alfred
hitchcock's psycho
they planned to pull the rug out from
under the audience by killing jack
midway through the first episode
forcing kate to take charge of course
jack
instead lives and gets off the island
only to return with other survivors who
made it home
the big mystery of the show ends up
being whether the survivors are dead
existing in an alternate universe or
experiencing some kind of strange shared
dream
and ultimately jack does end up biting
the bullet
just much later than originally planned
the fx drama pose is loud proud and
unapologetic
set in new york beginning in the late
80s it follows the lives of gay and
transgender people who participate in
the city's underground ballroom scene
brought to life by a cast that consists
of multiple trans actors
in 2019 co-creator ryan murphy and
producer janet mock
talked with deadline about the decision
to have fan favorite candy ferocity
killed in the second season
played by angelica ross candy is a
member of the house of ferocity who's
often mocked by ballroom announcer pray
tell
but she's true to her name as a
ferocious force to be reckoned with
and her death is deeply felt in the
community mock told deadline
our hardest thing was which character to
kill so once we figured out which
character
we kind of plotted the whole first half
of the season around losing candy
and really showing what that would look
like the decision was necessary to the
story as they built it
but mock and murphy also felt it was
important to shed light on the violence
that trans women were facing then
and still face today we will never again
get the opportunity to
tell her what she meant to us to thank
her
for what she gave us on the british
period drama downton abbey
lady sybil crawley as played by jessica
brown finley
is the youngest daughter of robert and
cora crawley the earl and countess of
grantham
along with her very different sisters
she maneuvers through high society
and the complicated social pressures
that come with her position
she makes great efforts to set herself
apart intermingling with classes deemed
lesser than her own
she even falls in love with an irish
driver named tom spurning the turned up
noses of her aristocratic family
the couple are able to welcome a
daughter but sybil tragically dies from
childbirth complications
worried about being stuck on a
never-ending series brown finley set her
terms well before the show began
as downton abbey creator julian fellowes
told vanity fair in 2015
jessica had said she was going to leave
right from the beginning
she said i'm doing three years then i'm
leaving so
that was all worked out is there
anything we should do mr carson
carry on daisy
as we all must check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one